[Music]
descendants tube was one of the hottest
events of summer 2017
in fact over 20 million people tuned in
to watch there's no doubt that you were
among them stay tuned until the end of
this video to find out just how much
thought the cast and crew put into
empowering young females everywhere
before we take you behind the scenes of
this instant Disney Channel Classic be
sure to like this video and subscribe
now here are ten behind the scenes
stories from dissonance two that you
need to hear dedication to history as
we're sure that most of you already know
the descendants films follow the
complicated lives of many of the
children of famous Disney movie villains
struggling with their identities and
their wish of permanently escaping the
dreaded Isle of the Lost
among the new cast members added to the
series was china anne mcclain an actress
best known for her work on Tyler Perry's
House of Payne and Disney Channel's
animated descendants TV show where she
voiced the character Freddy Chyna was
clearly a Disney Channel favorite and
she also starred in their series ant
farm and their original movie how to
build a better boy ultimately Chyna was
brought on to dissonance too by director
Kenny Ortega to play uma the daughter of
the villainous sea witch Ursula for
those of you who don't remember your own
childhood Ursula was the monster who
made Ariel's life difficult in the
Disney classic The Little Mermaid in
order to get into the tone of
descendants to gain inspiration and
prepare herself for the difficult role
China claims that she viewed the Little
Mermaid upwards of 20 times China
clearly had immense respect for the
beloved material that came before her
and used it to be able to influence her
performance and pay homage to the fans
good job China we think it paid off real
life sets so many of the awe-inspiring
sets that you saw and the decisions to
were actually built practically for the
actors to be able to work on in an age
where it's almost less time consuming
and less expensive for filmmakers to
construct all of the necessary locations
entirely with computer-generated images
director Kinney Ortega decided that he
wanted to use a more old-school approach
for Kinney whose resume includes hocus
pocus and the colossal hit High School
Musical movies this isn't out of the
ordinary but four main streams
that spends most of their story time in
whimsical fantasy worlds that need to be
created from scratch
shooting with green screens has become
the absolute norm but some directors
like Kenny
she's a practical approach to facing
this challenge in order to garner more
realistic performances you have to use
less of their imaginations if they have
something physical to work with real
sets also cast real shadows so visual
effects editors don't need to add them
later on
among the mini sets built for
descendants too was the gargantuan
pirate ship which was created in a
studio in Vancouver Canada the water
surrounding it with CGI but the actors
actually had an opportunity to sing and
dance and what looks like a real-life
pirate ship it doesn't get much cooler
than that the costume one of the most
iconic aspects of the dissonance movies
is the wild and whimsical costumes that
drape each of our heroes and villains
every characters outfit states a lot
about who they are and where they come
from something that's deeply connected
to the title of the franchise for
example one of the jackets made for dub
Chairman's mouth has a dragon designs
into the back of it to pay homage to her
wicked mother
Maleficent not only do the costumes need
to represent the character but they also
have to be fully functional something
that can't be taken for granted in a
movie where the actors have to do a lot
of moving around whether it's dancing or
fighting Karis on the costume designer
custom created a total of 1,500 costumes
for the second movie of course most of
the costumes were created for the film
starring character mal played by the
beautiful dove Cameron 100 yards of
fabric were used to create just one of
mouth' dresses another Tivat from behind
the scenes of the creation of Mouse
clothing is at her heels bred least
eight inches high to give the
notoriously short actress some height
when next to her co-stars if this
doesn't prove how important the great
costume designer is to a film we don't
know what does rehearsals with an
audience
according to Dylan play fair who played
Gaston son Gil in the movie the actors
were given the opportunity to perform
many of their scenes out in front of a
live studio audience
just like how they would if de Simmons
two were a play the crowd mostly
consisted of friends and
family of the cast and crew but even
still this is pretty uncommon for movies
of this scale the studio's usually do
their utmost to keep their films secrets
under wraps so things aren't spoiled
before the film's release after all we
do live in an age of constant internet
spoilers the event took place right at
the tail end of rehearsals before the
performers were brought to set to begin
filming when in production it's very
routine for big dance numbers to be shot
out of sequence and not start to finish
this is usually due to scheduling
conflicts within the cast stunt
requirements or due to weather or
location issues because of this actors
tend not to receive a large immediate
reaction to the hard work they put into
practicing their dance scenes for months
Dylan shared that it was his favorite
behind-the-scenes memory because they
not only were able to share what they've
been involved with for their family and
close friends but also received some
fantastic positive feedback what a
special moment for them matching tattoos
the filmmaking process is notorious for
either bringing people together or
completely tearing them apart it's a
laborious endeavor chock-full of
incredibly long hours and abundance of
different frustrations and a heck of a
lot of big personalities due to the
tabloids we constantly hear about cast
mates who naturally butted heads or who
could no longer stand each other because
of the dramatic incidents that took
place on set it's easy to imagine how an
experience like going a movie like the
students to pick push people apart but
luckily this wasn't the case at all so
many cast members have discussed how
close they became after shooting the
film many of whom are still close
friends to this day including zuv
cameron and china anne mcclain but
what's particularly special about the
relationships forged on the set of
dissonance - was their tattoo adventure
much like the ensemble of the Lord of
the Rings trilogy served members of the
cast of the sentence - celebrated
finishing the movie by getting matching
tattoos those who engaged in this
adventure with the three new cast
members Chyna and McClain Thomas Doherty
and Dylan Playfair the three of them
share the majority of their screen time
together and became fast friends even
while having a lot of stressful
responsibilities like fight training and
dance choreography what a beautiful way
to commemorate their journey together
Cameron's makeover characters often go
through drastic transformations over the
course of a story especially
that story continues through more than
one film sometimes the metamorphosis is
more than just an emotional one
it's occasionally physical as well if
you've seen dissonance - you may have
noticed that Cameron voices character
Carlos didn't look exactly like he did
in the first movie this is because the
filmmakers wanted to continue Carlos's
journey away from being the son of his
evil 101 dalmatians mother Cruella de
Vil his hair transformation was the most
drastic as he traded in his curly locks
for a more straight edged look the hair
that you see in the movie is in fact a
wig Cameron explains that achieving this
look took hours of preparation in the
hair and makeup chair each morning it
started with him getting his natural
hair slicked down while he got his beard
shaved and then having his platinum
blonde wig glued to his head some fans
are upset that Carlos no longer rocked
his curly mane but it seems like this
change was important to the
transformation of his character Cameron
is happy that his character got to bring
more to the table than just being the
comedic relief and was able to develop
past his family's history
this included evolving his since
subscribe after seeing the movie we can
say that were happy - Cameron
sword fighting dissonance - was a truly
far more physically demanding movie for
the cast than the film's predecessor not
only was there a lot more dancing
including weeks of rehearsals with a
total of 52 dancers but there was also a
significant amount of fight instruction
involved dude - booboo Stewart's
character Jay swords and shields fencing
team at auradon prep and a number of
pirate characters in the film so our
training became the most prevalent in
the lives of the cast there have been a
ton of gripping and awe-inspiring sword
fights in cinema history to go through
the list of movies would simply take too
long but it seems that the key to
pulling off successful ones is to make
each fight appear to be unrehearsed this
creates a feeling of danger and real
stakes as well as it takes serious
acting chops to make it feel new in
order to truly convince the audience of
this the cast of dissonance 2 had to
endure more than 20 hours of soar
training with highly skilled sword
masters you can see how much this
training paid off in to elaborate sword
fights one in the prep school and the
other when Malin umas gangs face off the
heavy edition of this - The Descendants
universe is a great added pressure for
fans of all ages romantic backstory for
better or for worse young
seems to be unstoppable in some cases
not even a healthy paycheck can stop it
examples of such people would be Duff
Cameron and series newcomer Thomas
Doherty the pair publicly announced
their relationship in February 2017 but
it seems they were all over each other
months prior during the production of
descendants - though their characters
mal and Harry Hooke have a platonic
relationship on-screen Dov and Thomas
created a romantic backstory to add a
little more depth to their characters as
well as to honor their budding real-life
affair though it's not officially part
of the Canon dumped all the j14 that her
and Thomas believed that mal and Harry
once shared a vibrant romantic
relationship it makes sense that the
reformed villain s daughter of
Maleficent would have a past Trice with
the bad boys son of Captain Hook dub
claims with the two were each other's
first love before
uma and now had a falling-out this
caused the lovers to part ways as Harry
had an allegiance to Emma though Mau
eventually became one of the good guys
she still bears a small hook tattoo on
her hand to remember Harry though it's
not something that is developed
on-screen director Kim ER tag I like the
idea as long as they both hid their
matching hook tattoos under their
characters gloves
this is either a beautiful sign of
real-life luck or a bit of an obsession
you be the judge the final dance
director Kenny Ortega was certain that
he wanted to top the ending of the
enormous ly successful first descendents
movie when creating its sequel according
to The Hollywood Reporter he felt that
he owed it to 100 million people across
the globe who turned in to enjoy the
first Disney Channel hit film lucky for
him and us this is something that he
most certainly accomplished after the
massive climax were Malin uma faced off
the final dance sequence took place I'm
a gigantic flooded yacht deck this was a
visually stunning piece of work that
allowed the large cast to kick up water
as they danced and sang their hearts out
though filming the scene did pose some
problems with safety and continuity with
the water the movie moment ultimately
turned out and has been forever placed
in our imaginations to accomplish the
scene two huge water cannons were
required to continuously soak the deck
though the cast was excited about
playing around in the water his sequence
required them to go through a large
amount of
network as well as costume makeup and
hair tests to be able to pull it all off
of course we now know that all of their
hard work was enjoyed by millions and
descendants - has become the biggest
Disney Channel movie ever made
empowering females it's easy to see how
this isn't Stu with largely garner a
female audience with its portrayal of
dynamic young women though the director
Kimmy Ortega design the second film in
this franchise to contain a lot more
action so that young boys would be
encouraged to tune in to he never forgot
that his material can empower girls to
love and respect themselves for whoever
they may be in fact many of the cast
members including Doug Cameron and
Sophia Carson also claimed that they
spent a lot of time considering how
their roles with impact young females
across the globe dove in particular
spend significant time thinking about
this as the movie features her character
in losing and regaining her authentic
identity in the public life dove appears
to be an intellectual beauty queen but
during the production of this movie she
wanted other girls to know that they
could be more than that
dove ended up doing all of her own
stunts in her 8-inch Hills no less
showing us that women can be beautiful
fashionable intelligent brave and be
intimidating simultaneously empowering
females carried over into offset life
with the strong friendships developed
between the cast mates dev and Sophia
who plays Evie the whip-smart fashion
designer who made her dreams come true
without the help of her prints are
exceptionally close it's admire about
that so much effort went into creating
positive role models for the women of
tomorrow we applaud the cast and crew of
descendants - that's it for 10
behind-the-scenes stories from
descendants - you need to hear did any
of these stories surprise you
let us know in the comments and be sure
to subscribe to this channel to see more
videos like this one thanks for watching
[Music]